[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a diario de copas el espacio
de france 24 para seguir el desarrollo
de la copa américa y la eurocopa estos
son nuestros titulares
brasil y perú juegan la primera
semifinal de la copa américa en río de
janeiro la verdad madre la gran favorita
debe definir el reemplazo de gabriel
jesús la blanquirroja no contará con
andré carrillo analizamos este encuentro
la primera eurocopa con múltiples sedes
ella ha dado lugar a varios hitos el
experimento de la uefa se sobrepuso a la
pandemia y en lo futbolístico ha dejado
varios récords para destacar hacemos un
primer balance de la competencia a una
semana de su final
y el torneo deja atrás los viajes para
centrarse en londres el mítico wembley
recibirá a las semifinales y la final en
pleno fervor del público local que se
ilusiona con la primera eurocopa para
inglaterra tenemos informes de reino
unidos
[Música]
como cada jornada nos acompañan zara
castro directora del diario 'as'
colombia será bienvenida
un gusto federico yo empezamos la cuenta
regresiva para las finales y empezamos
con la copa américa que no da respiro y
este lunes se disputan la primera
semifinal en río de janeiro es en el
estadio 'olímpico' nilton santos allí
brasil enfrentará a perú en una
reedición de la final de 2019 la verde
manera no contará con el expulsado
gabriel jesús mientras que la
blanquirroja perdió a andré carrillo una
de sus figuras en el historial general
la canarinha tiene una amplia ventaja y
un antecedente cercano del 4 a 0 en la
fase de grupos en la única derrota de
perú en lo que va del torneo la
blanquirroja se agarra de que sus tres
triunfos en duelos competitivos fueron
por copa américa que la última derrota
de brasil como local en una copa américa
fue en 1975 torneo que peruano y que
bajo el mandato de ricardo gareca ya
venció dos veces al 'scratch' sala
brasil y perú han jugado mucho en el
último tiempo se cruzan por tercera copa
américa consecutiva sin duda han a ver
de manera es la gran favorita y ti te
tendrá que definir cómo reemplazar a
gabriel jesús hasta aquí había mantenido
esa especie de cuarto
de cuatro delanteros prácticamente pero
una posibilidad es que ingrese lucas
para que está que le podría dar de
distinto a brasil el jugador del
olympique de lyon
lo primero es eso son dos rivales más
que conocidos y no creo que la
estrategia ni el sistema de ti te
cambien yo creo que se mantendrá con ese
424 la diferencia en este punto es que
para que está entraría a reemplazar
básicamente la posición de gabriel jesús
pero lo que él juega es con dos medios
con casemiro y fred y luego dos
articuladores que vendrían a ser neymar
y firmino para generar juego y dos
delanteros por fuera que siempre caigan
al espacio y creo que en eso para que
tal no cambiaría mucho digamos la
versatilidad que tiene hasta este punto
brasil que es lo que insiste ti te que
quiere un equipo equilibrado y volvemos
a ese sistema táctico en el que quiere
un equipo que defienda bien que el que
esté más libre sea neymar pero que pueda
generar esa conexión con firmino para
hacer daño sin duda es el favorito del
torneo no sólo por todo el trabajo
conseguido sino además por el valor que
le ha dado tite a los jugadores que
incluso tiene en el banco aunque ya dejó
de hacer este tinte que desde las ruedas
de prensa nos contaban
anticipaba cuál era la nómina titular él
dice que es un tema estratégico en este
punto la no confirmación de lucas para
que está en esa posición y deja también
digamos en el tintero se iba a poner a
alexandro un lateral con unas
características diferentes a las de
renal lo di pero más allá de eso este
equipo está muy rodado muy trabajado
tiene un engranaje que funciona
perfectamente y no debería tener
problemas ante perú enfrente está
precisamente este equipo blanquirrojo
que no ha mostrado su mejor versión en
el torneo tiene antecedentes sobre todo
en la era gareca de haber complicado a
brasil hizo una buena final en 2019 por
ejemplo pero necesita la sensación que
necesita algo más cuando o dar algo más
respecto de lo que viene mostrando para
complicar a este brasil que tiene que
puede hacer gareca para complicar
justamente a brasil
gareca ha venido trabajando variantes en
el sistema y parece que eso es lo que va
a hacer frente a brasil seguiría con una
línea de cinco defensas
estoy intentando emular un poco la que
lo que ya le vimos a colombia llenar el
ancho de la cancha darle muy pocos
espacios por las bandas a brasil sin
embargo hay que tener en cuenta que el
juego interior también es muy importante
y hablábamos que neymar y firmino
empezarían a intercambiarse a generar
esa conexión para poner en problemas a
ese mediocampo de perú en el eje
estarían yotún y tapia que son
fundamentales pero claro falta carrillo
que es esa cuota de desequilibrio y de
posibilidades de llegada también en
velocidad de aprovechamiento de espacios
para perú es un partido muy complicado
desde lo táctico vamos a ver qué plantea
gareca pero no creo que sea nada muy
diferente a lo que ya sabía colombia
creo que colombia puso ese punto alto de
a brasil se le puede jugar se le puede
hacer un gol colectivo como el que se le
hizo pero además de intentar tapar los
espacios veremos cómo está el estado de
la cancha una de las grandes
preocupaciones de ti está en esta copa
américa porque sin duda a los que más
los cuestas a los que tienen que salir a
proponer cómo es el equipo brasileño que
además es local dejamos de lado por un
momento la copa américa pasamos a la
eurocopa que espera por las semifinales
a disputarse martes y miércoles con
acción centralizada en londres es un
buen momento para hacer balance de esta
primera edición multi sede de la
historia la uefa siguió adelante con su
plan pensa en las preocupaciones por la
pandemia y al margen de lo sanitario el
torneo ha dado frutos en lo futbolístico
edición con más goles convertidos con
135 hasta el momento y con más tantos en
propia puerta con 10 atendiendo el día
con más goles en la historia del torneo
con los 18 anotados el 23 de junio y ha
sido escenario de récords de equipos e
individuales en particular
vale destacar a cristiano ronaldo el
jugador con más goles marcados más
partidos disputados y que alcanzó
también al idae como el máximo anotador
en selecciones nacionales con 19 109
goles para este torneo no se ha regalado
grandes partidos sus sorpresas equipos
que se animan incluso con menos recursos
que balances se pueden hacer hasta aquí
a una semana del final esto esta
eurocopa nos ha dado felicidad a los
hinchas del fútbol lo primero es hablar
de las once sedes realmente ha sido un
éxito en cuanto a la organización
volvieron los públicos a la tribuna se
ha visto diversidad más allá de la
decisión de la uefa de no dejar usar el
arco iris en el estadio de múnich yo
creo que en general hemos visto eso
alegría festividad en las tribunas y eso
también nos hace recuperar la confianza
en general en tiempos tan complicados
luego en los datos de todos estos
recortes nos son menores
hablamos de 135 goles en 48 partidos
esto es una medida de 2.8
muchos goles y que nos hace referencia a
esto a que muchos de los planteamientos
han sido valientes incluso equipos
tácticos como austria no sólo se
defienden atrás sino que siempre buscan
hacer daño al rival eso es fundamental
para todo lo que estamos viendo luego
ésta no ha sido una eurocopa de grandes
figuras
sino de colectivos muchos equipos
colectivos muy bien trabajados muy bien
aceitados en una idea y es muy llamativo
esto no quiere decir que no haya grandes
figuras en cada uno de los equipos pero
no ha habido en esta esta figura del
caudillo que arrastre a su equipo y lo
lleve a clasificaciones sino que en
general ha sido mucho trabajo colectivo
españa es el más goleador el que empezó
con problemas para para convertir 12
goles y el segundo es dinamarca y esto
habla también de la versatilidad táctica
y de las diferentes maneras como los
entrenadores europeos están consiguiendo
poner un nivel altísimo el ritmo la
dinámica de esta eurocopa creo que nos
deja en un nivel que competitivamente no
habíamos visto hace mucho tiempo y esto
vuelve a acercar a los fanáticos también
al fútbol y demuestra también que las
distancias se achican
en europa ahora la acción se va a
centrar en londres en el mítico estadio
de wembley donde se jugarán las
semifinales y la final una etapa que
tendrá multitudes a pesar de las
inquietudes por el coach 19 y en medio
del fervor de los fanáticos ingleses que
ven cerca una posible consagración desde
la capital del reino unido a nuestra
corresponsal luis pulido nos cuenta más
en furia colectiva se respira aquí en
inglaterra por la posibilidad cada vez
más cercana de que el equipo inglés se
corone campeón de esta eurocopa 2021 por
supuesto hay gran expectativa de un
nuevo triunfo frente a dinamarca este
miércoles inglaterra no juega una
semifinal hace 25 años y si gana esta
será la primera final que juega desde
1966 cuando ganó el mundial de fútbol
por supuesto los hinchas están tratando
de cazar las boletas existentes para
presenciar este momento histórico en el
mítico estadio de wembley que recibirá a
casi 70.000 espectadores con un 75 por
ciento de su capacidad todos los que
tengan esta suerte de presenciar este
partido tendrán que presentar una prueba
negativa de kobe además de un
certificado de vacunas y sólo podrán
retirarse la mascarilla una vez sentados
en el estadio esto aplica para los
hinchas desde los 11 años
eurocopa que se juega aquí en londres y
en otras ciudades europeas ha traído
esperanza y felicidad al país los
hinchas han vuelto a abrazarse pese
aunque aún no es permitido por las
restricciones de distancia social pero
lo cierto es que cada vez más hinchas
cantan al unísono y cantan eufóricamente
fútbol es coming home
y usted aquí pueden les muestras tanto
una firmeza de lo futbolístico como una
unión colectiva en particular que le ha
generado cierto vínculo con los
fanáticos tienen motivos para
ilusionarse genera mucha ilusión es que
todas las palabras que usaba la
corresponsal son eso histórico mítico es
muy importante para europa en lo que
representa en la historia del fútbol y
que definitivamente no ha conseguido los
triunfos que debería a nivel de
selección que esta final se dispute ahí
y con esta generación de jugadores south
gate creo que ha sabido gestionar muy
bien esa presión no de contar con este
grupo histórico y gestionarlo a su
manera bajo su idea y una idea súper
clara que ya lo hemos dicho aquí que es
una propuesta sin fisuras sin duda creo
que este final ford va a ser muy
emocionante muy interesante y el fútbol
vuelve a casa y creo que todos los que
hemos seguido la historia del deporte
hace que esto sea muy emocionante y sin
duda vamos a ver partidos muy
interesantes y con un clima más que
particular con esa cantidad de gente que
va a ver tanto en las semifinales como
en la final así que en wembley en diario
de copas en repasamos otras noticias
también vinculadas a la euro
en español roberto martínez se seguirá
siendo el seleccionador de bélgica el
consejero delegado de la federación
belga peter voser aseguró que cuentan
con el entrenador para encarar la
clasificación al mundial de qatar-2022
la eliminación en cuartos de final de la
eurocopa había despertado algunas
críticas y dudas sobre la continuidad de
la estrategia con contrato hasta después
del próximo mundial
españa realizó su último entrenamiento
antes de la semifinal ante italia pablo
sarabia volvió a estar ausentes por
molestias musculares y lo evaluarán a
último momento para ver si puede ser de
la partida la buena noticia para luis
enrique fue la reincorporación del
defensa de américa port tras superar una
fatiga muscular
italia ya está en londres para afrontar
la semifinal ante españa roberto mancini
no tiene dudas en su equipo titular con
el único cambio de emerson palmieri por
leonardo spinazzola que se rompió el
tendón de aquiles izquierdo en los
cuartos de final ante bélgica
bueno hasta aquí diario de copas muchas
gracias por estar nuevamente con
nosotros hoy como siempre un gusto y
creo que se vienen los mejores partidos
de las copas y así nos estaremos
siguiendo a ustedes muchas gracias por
estar del otro lado sigan con más en
france 24 y france24 puntocom
i
[Música]